hey guys how's it goin I'm Justine
welcome to tech Tuesday I'm so excited
about today's episode because this is
something that I have been waiting for
for so long and I can't believe it's
finally here I can't believe I actually
haven't I can't believe I get to show it
to you right now today we're talking
about the FLIR one it's an iPhone case
will turn your iPhone into a thermal
imaging camera it's awesome you could do
photos you could do videos there's a
bunch of different apps that are made
from FLIR that lets you do a bunch of
different things you could do time-lapse
you can do a sort of close up macro
shots because this actually has two
cameras so the one is the thermal
imaging and the one is actually a
regular camera so when you take the
photos in the video you will actually
kind of get a thermal image over a real
image so it's more clear what exactly it
is that you're looking at so this is the
box I already opened it as you can tell
it comes with this iPhone case that's
specifically made for the actual case so
you can just slide it right in like this
this little hook will hook on to this
hole it also comes with a micro USB
cable as you can see here and this
microphone extender so you can still use
your microphone and your audio with the
case on this is the front of the case
this is your switch it has three
different modes it has closed which it's
closed right now this is open and this
here is your tune so when you put this
on your camera you'll have to tune the
image each time you change different
scenes it's basically like your white
balancing the image lock your flare into
place you look great
we're attached flip the switch to the
middle position and now we're going to
tune I'm so freakin excited you can take
pictures something a little bit sure
myself so because these two cameras are
so close together you have to use
another app if you want to take pictures
that are close up so the image will
actually be aligned it works perfect
when things are a little bit further
away because it's able to adjust for the
depth of field and kind of pull
everything into perspective so okay I'm
going to make a little video here
there's just like a little option to
switch from photo to video right here so
we're doing video this is kind of crazy
cuz my xbox is so hot it's not even on
either which is insane
my computer monitor is really hot well
my router real hot and you're going to
edit you can switch through the
different little filters here so you've
got contrast yeah it's so awesome
there's so many different little
settings that you can do this will show
you the battery life of your device you
can click on the spot meter of course
every time you do something new just
make sure you tune it so you'll be able
to get the most accurate read so it'll
give you real-time temperature info how
hot am i I don't know now take you guys
on a little tour of my house and see if
I can find some things that are really
hot oh look at me I'm sweating hot Xbox
hot my poor little PC back Larry he's
real hot holy crap hot messy bedroom the
drinks cold how about the TV whoa you
HOT oh yes see some hotness over there
oh you're hot hot 32 degrees Fahrenheit
in this well guess what the freezer is
freezing thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this tech
Tuesday because I had so much fun with
this thing and I can't wait to take it
out and go on a Squatch watch hunt which
is really funny because I originally
found the FLIR company because of
watching Discovery's Finding Bigfoot
I'll see you guys on the next check
Tuesday and I'll probably see you
tomorrow in another video and I'll say
don't post one so who knows I love you
guys thanks for watching you're awesome
I'll see you later
right